not a pretty day on january 6 when the
brutality and the pain and the struggle
on display during that day did not end
on january 6th in fact in quick
succession in the days after
four police officers who fought that
violent mob went on to take their own
lives all in the wake of the attack
now in an exclusive interview with cbs
news the widow of one of those officers
is talking about the battle she waged in
the 14 months since her husband's death
scott mcfarland shows how it could
affect law enforcement families in every
american community scott this is a big
story good morning
tony good morning to you aaron smith
says her husband d.c police officer jeff
smith had no history of mental illness
or depression until he came home from
work from here on january 6.
jeff was
funny he was
a jokester d.c police officer jeff smith
had a family he loved a dog he loved and
his wife aaron told us a career he loved
being a police officer it was his
calling he knew that's what he wanted to
do that's what he should be doing he did
but he had no idea what awaited him on
january 6 2021 when he and his riot unit
raced to the capitol
body camera footage obtained by cbs news
reveals jeff arrived on the front lines
as rioter ashley babbitt was shot and
killed
while trying to breach a smashed window
near the u.s house floor they were in
the hallway and the first thing that he
could remember hearing was shots fired
how did he characterize it he
characterized january 6 as the worst day
of his life after hours fighting off the
mob aaron says jeff returned home in the
early morning with a black eye and in an
even darker mood i went to sleep and
then the next day his demeanor changed
and he was never the same what changed
he didn't want to talk
he was pacing at night
and during the day
sleeplessness sleeplessness the joke
stopped
the dancing around the house stopped
jeff went to the police medical clinic
the night of the attack to report a blow
to the head but notes from a follow-up
visit a week later reviewed by cbs news
do not show he was asked about his
mental health and then one night aaron
says she woke up to find him crying in
bed what did you think was going on
truthfully i wasn't sure
i tried to console him tell him
everything was going to be okay
i just told him that i loved him and
that
we'll get through whatever this is
nine days after january 6th jeff smith
took his own life one of four officers
who died by suicide in the seven months
after responding to the attack i think
the
physical attack on him
changed him and if he didn't go to work
that day
he'd still be here it was just the
beginning of aaron's loss like most
jurisdictions d.c did not consider any
suicide a line of duty death denying
aaron much of the family's income health
insurance and ceremonial honors
capitol police officer brian siknik
suffered fatal strokes the day after
january 6 ruled a line of duty death he
laid in state while aaron smith received
nothing no notes no recognition
nothing from the city nothing from the
department
and
it's hurtful
and it's sad that they can't even reach
out to
the widow of one of their own officers
it literally stops the pace stops 30
days after the death with the help of
attorney david weber smith decided to
fight dc on its decision weber said the
burden was on them to make the case
january 6th cause jeff's death
they say they found the proof in jeff's
body cam footage you see he's getting
jostled here he's getting jostled slowed
down weber contends the video shows
someone in the mob sees jeff's baton
allegedly striking him with it right
there it's gone now you're going to see
him fall backwards then there's this now
outside the capitol a metal pole sails
in from the crowd hitting jeff head on
he took shelter in a stairwell
there was a physical injury that took
place here we are able to prove that he
suffered a traumatic brain injury it was
more than a year until d.c agreed
earlier this month aaron received this
letter declaring jeff died from an
injury sustained while performing his
duties on january 6. why do you think it
took so long for the district of
columbia to determine that with a
suicide comes
a stigma and
something that the police department
doesn't want to face or recognize i
think she's a hero illinois democrat
tammy duckworth and texas republican
john cornyn say they hope this ruling
lays down a marker for the three other
officers who died by suicide after the
sixth it was a traumatic event and i
think it's entirely appropriate that the
law enforcement
officials be covered and for police
families nationwide the two senators
have introduced legislation to allow for
line of duty death designations when
police officers take their own lives
more than 750 officers have died by
suicide since 2017. the military has
made this pivot understanding that
injuries to the brain to the psyche is
just as important as an injury to the
body aaron smith is advocating for the
bill what do you think jeff would say
about this issue i believe he would be
proud of me right now i'm fighting for
my husband
but i'm also fighting for everyone else
who has gone through this as well
and it deserves
the recognition
if the legislation passes for officers
who die by suicide after january 1st
2019 there'd be eligibility for line of
duty benefits the d.c police department
and the mayor of the district of
columbia did not comment for our report
but as for erin smith she tells us she
has not brought herself to watch that
body camera video telling us quote
i relive it every day
live
scott uh aaron smith is a hero just as
her husband was tony you wanted that
yeah and i just want to add that you
know tammy duckworth senator duckworth
is absolutely right the military has
recognized this that there's such a
thing as physical
injury but also a moral injury that's a
term or a spiritual injury and it sounds
like the law enforcement if this bill
passes may take that view as well uh
which is what happened in this case
seems clear to me yeah um scott you're
reporting as always spectacular thank
you for sharing this important story our
heart goes out to those
who are all affected by that terrible
day thank you scott